when a movie bombs hard enough it earns
a rather notorious place in the history
books
as time goes on the world's biggest
cinematic flops come to be regarded as
legends or at the very least they carry
some serious name recognition
after all who doesn't remember the
ridiculously expensive failure that was
water world
what about geely the ben affleck
jennifer lopez gangster flick that was
so bad it got yanked out of theaters in
just
three weeks these films though are
high-profile
failures while they certainly lost the
studio some major dough
they didn't set any records for being
the lowest grossing movie of all time
instead that dubious distinction goes to
a movie that
fittingly enough you've probably never
heard of
even though it was a thriller that
starred two popular actors in catherine
heigl
and tom sizemore zizzix road opened in
u.s theaters in february of 2006
between a weird title that microsoft
word underlines in red
a budget of 1.2 million dollars and a
bizarre release strategy
the film earned a total gross lower than
your average grocery trip
here's why first off about the title no
it's not a typo even though southwest
locals will correctly tell you that it
looks an awful lot like
xyzx which is a real place in california
as for some background on the film
itself since given the box office gross
you never saw it
it stars leo grillo as an accountant
named grant who goes to vegas and gets
involved with a woman named marissa
played by catherine heigl they murder
her ex-boyfriend joey played by tom
sizemore and card his corpse off to the
desert
only to find out he's still alive
zizik's road was written produced and
directed by john penny
and was something of a passion project
it made thirty dollars in theaters
yes you heard right during its entire
theatrical run
only six people paid money to see the
film this movie is a total
disappointment no thought went into it
no effort went into it as insane as that
sounds
hold your laughter because this abysmal
profit while it might technically be the
lowest gross ever
comes with a big asterisk namely that
nobody was supposed to buy tickets for
that particular run of zyzzix road in
the first place
as explained by entertainment weekly the
marketing plan was to pursue
international sales first then do a
domestic release later on
however the name actors had accepted a
lower pay rate for the sake of the
production
and the strict rules of the screen
actors guild required that for them to
do so
there needed to be a domestic release in
theaters first
the solution the production rented a
single theater in texas
and showed the movie only once a day for
six days straight
nobody was supposed to know once the
media found out though
there was no stuffing the cat back in
the bag john penny was heartbroken when
the mocking headlines emerged
he told entertainment weekly i was
mortified this movie is like my baby and
it's being dragged around in the street
with people poking sticks in it it was
brutal
it was ugly i was reeling embarrassing
as the scenario may seem though
the notoriety helped bring attention to
the film and regardless
everyone who understands the business
knows that the fact that it only made 30
bucks at the box office
is really not that important because
once the film started putting out dvds
the international market alone netted
368
000 in 23 countries meanwhile though
these media shenanigans may have caused
another film's reputation to get hit
even harder than physics road
in february of 2006 the exact same time
in history where zizzix road set a new
low point in ticket sales
another thriller movie was released
titled xyz
xyz also involves murder in the
southwest u.s desert that said
between the similar plot lines and the
similar titles
xyz often gets confused with sizzix road
to this day
probably for the sake of making space
from the more well-known release
some subsequent releases of xyzax have
been retitled burned
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one